[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CROWD NOISE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining
us on I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
I'm Emily Fortuna.
If you can't be here this
week at I/O, don't worry.
We're here for you.
Visit g.co/io/live to watch
and rewatch the keynotes
and sessions, plus all the
exclusive interviews and demos
our team of Googlers will be
bringing you over the next
days.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
First up, we welcome
Manuel Bronstein, VP of Product
Management here at Google
to talk to us about the next
generation of Google Assistant.
Manuel, thanks for joining us.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Thanks
for having me here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Let's go really big
picture for a moment.
When you think about how
the Google Assistant changes
people's everyday lives for the
better, what does it look like?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Yeah.
So when we thought
about the product,
our mission is to be the
best way to get things done.
And when we say best, we
think about seamless, fastest,
easiest way to get things done.
And if you think
about our world,
in some ways it's getting
more complex, right?
Every time you try
to do something,
you need to think about not
only what you want to do,
but the how.
And if we do our
job right and we're
investing to make
it happen, you want
to be able to go
from what do I want
to get done to getting it done
without having to worry about
the how, in many ways.
And our hope is that
that saves you time.
And we all know how
important it is for all of us
to get a little bit more time
to do all the things that we
care about.
So we're very proud
to be investing
in making the product the
best way to get things done.
In many ways, to
give users time back.
EMILY FORTUNA: So the
Assistant is becoming
more and more personalized.
How does that help us, as well?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: So
think about-- when
people think about
an Assistant, they're
thinking about a
product that is going
to learn from them, that
is going to understand
what they're saying.
And in order for the system to
understand what you're saying,
it needs to
understand your role.
Right?
If I say call my
wife, it needs to know
that my wife is [? Ariana ?]
and what number to call.
If I say set an
appointment for my kids,
it should understand
who my kids are.
So when the system starts
getting to know you,
or it even knows where
is home, where is work--
so that I can know, hey,
when I'm asking it to give me
a direction, I said,
like, drive me to work--
it can understand that.
The system becomes more
useful because you can speak
to it in a more natural way.
You don't have to
think about addresses
or you don't have to
think about commands.
You speak to it the same way
you would speak to a friend.
And then it will understand
what you're trying
to do and help you get it done.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What is
your favorite new feature
that Assistant
announced today and why?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: I mean, it's
really hard to pick a favorite.
The team worked really, really
hard on many of the things
that we announced today.
I think that when you
think about the promise
of the Assistant being the
best way to get things done,
when it starts
getting really fast.
And what we announced
with the next generation
Assistant, one of the
key things about it--
and we're seeing it in
a very proud way-- which
is imagine that it starts
understanding you so fast so
quickly that speaking into your
phone is faster than tapping.
Or that tapping your phone
is going to feel slow.
That's when you know
that you hit something
that could change
user behavior and get
people to start embedding
themselves into this product.
Because it's actually
becoming very simple, but also
very fast and very
efficient in helping you
get your tasks done.
EMILY FORTUNA: That's great.
So in the past
couple years, we've
seen Assistant play
a much larger role
in homes and phones.
And now in driving--
so can you tell us about
the experience for drivers
and what that's like.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Yeah.
I mean, when you think
about using your voice
and being hands free,
actually, the car
is a perfect environment
for it, right?
Hopefully, people are
driving, and they're
looking at the road.
They're not looking
at their phones.
They're not touching
the screens--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You don't
mean hands-free driving?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN:
Hands-free driving--
no.
It's hands-free phone.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hands on the wheel.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Not on the phone.
Yeah.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Correct.
So when you think about
it, actually, the car
is one of the places where
the Assistant can be even more
helpful, right?
But the car is a
hard environment.
Because if your windows are
down, there's a lot of noise.
You may lose connectivity
and so forth.
But one of the things that
we started thinking about
is let's start from
the user and what
is that thing that
you're trying to get
done when you're in your car.
I mean, there are mainly
three things, right?
You're trying to
navigate from point A
to point B. You want to
get to the place hopefully
fast and safe.
You also want to make sure
that when you're in the car
you can get entertained, right?
So you want to listen to music
or podcast or radio, right?
And then of course, you
sometimes want to communicate.
You want to make
a phone call, you
want to receive a text message,
or send a text message.
And think about doing all
these things with your hands
while you're driving-- it's
probably not the right way
to do it.
It's not safe.
But when you started doing
each of these scenarios,
like driving from
point A to point B,
communicating or
listening to media,
and you can control
that with your voice,
and it understands exactly
what you're trying to get done,
then the product
becomes very magical.
Because it's really
solving a real need
and a real problem
in an environment
that needs that help.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Can you talk to us
about how the next generation
of the Google Assistant
will change the way that
people interact with it?
Yeah.
So if you think about when you
start forgetting about the how
and you start worrying about
what is it that you want to do,
you start relying on the
product in a very different way.
That's when the behavior
change starts to happen.
So in the first phase
of the Assistant,
it should be very
responsive to you.
It should understand
what you're saying
and then help you get it done.
As the product starts
learning from you,
it can start getting
more proactive.
So now when I get in my
car, it could flash to me
some missed calls or
voicemails that I have so
that if I want to return that
call, I'm reminded of that.
Or if it knows
that in my calendar
I have an appointment at
7 PM and it's 6 PM or 6:30
and I haven't left, and it also
knows the information of where
I'm trying to go and
knows the traffic,
it could actually
send me a notification
and let me know, hey, you're
probably going to be late
if you don't leave now.
And it's very interesting
when the product
starts getting more proactive.
I think that we're
going to see a switch.
I mean, I see it a
lot with my kids.
That in the same way that
when the screens became
touch screens and people felt
that every screen is touchable,
and you see a little kid
and they see an old TV
and they try to
touch on the screen
and the screen
doesn't work, I think
that people are
going to get used
to talking to their products and
expecting that the product will
understand what you're
saying in a natural way
and help you get it done.
And I think that we're
going to see that evolution
from basically understanding
your commands, what you want
to do and help you get
it done, to getting
very proactive, personal,
and more helpful,
so anticipating your
needs and the things
that you're trying
to accomplish.
EMILY FORTUNA: So you've got
Assistant on your phone, home,
and now driving.
Where do you see Assistants
going in the future?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: So,
it's a great question.
Look, I think that a personal
assistant needs to be with you.
So of course, a lot of the work
that the team has been doing
is making sure that the
product is available
where you need it the most.
I don't know
necessarily that it's
going to go to
different places, right?
I mean, at the end of the day,
we spend time in our homes,
we spend time at work, we
spend time in our cars,
we spend time with our phones--
maybe too much time
with our phones.
But if the product can
always be with you,
then it can help you fulfill
some of those things.
I think that in the future
what I'm hoping it helps--
I mean, if you think
about the areas
where people spend time
trying to get things done,
that they wish that--
you know, think about it, right?
When you want to
go to a restaurant,
the act of going
to the restaurant
and having a nice meal
is awesome, right?
Maybe calling to make a
reservation is not that great.
But if the product can start
doing those things for you
and remove that load
that load from you,
it becomes incredibly useful.
So I think that if you think
about more of those tasks
that people are trying to get
done, and help you anticipate
it, find that ticket
for an event for you
that you want to go to, making
that appointment for you,
and getting predictive
about those things,
then the product becomes
extremely magical.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Before you leave us,
are there any hints you can
give us to find some Easter
eggs in the Assistant?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Sure.
We recently launched a
new voice for the system
with John Legend.
And it's pretty cool.
And if you asked, actually, if
you turn the voice to the John
Legend voice for
Assistant, and you
ask it to sing a song for
you or sing happy birthday,
you're going to hear John
Legend singing for you.
And it's actually pretty cool.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Thank you, Manuel,
so much for sharing
your insights.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN:
So great to be here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Welcome
to the boardwalk at I/O.
This space really
captures the festival vibe
and it's one thing
that makes I/O special.
This year, we collaborate
with a bunch of artists
to combine our tech
with their talent.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This interactive
easel takes my doodles
and makes them museum
quality works of art.
So what I've drawn here is
obviously "Starry Night."
[LAUGHTER]
Whoa!
AUDIENCE: Hi!
EMILY FORTUNA: That's my job.
This art installation is
called "Mosaic Virus."
It uses machine
learning to create
flowers whose
appearance is based
on the fluctuation of bitcoin.
They're pretty nice.
I kind of want some of
these in my backyard.
I'm here with Kenric and Alex.
And they curated all of
the awesome works of art
here on the boardwalk.
Kenric, please tell us about
them and how you curated them.
KENRIC MCDOWELL: Well,
we've been working
with artists for a while.
And particularly in the work
I do working with artists,
I use artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
And so we wanted to highlight
some collaborative projects
by artists working with
machine learning that
provide representation
of natural phenomena,
like onformative's piece
here "Meandering River,"
or Anna Riddler's "Mosaic
Virus with Tulips."
So we really wanted people
to see images of themselves
in collaboration with nature
through machine learning.
EMILY FORTUNA: Very cool.
And you alluded to
this, Kenric, this
is an ongoing collaboration,
not just happening at I/O. Alex,
can you tell us
a little bit more
about the history behind that?
ALEX CZETWERTYNSKI: Yeah.
So for the last two years--
this is the third year
that we've been doing
an arts program at I/O.
And every year it grows.
And it feels great
to see how there's
support for this
kind of presentation
at an event like this.
And I think that this
year we're changing
the format a little bit.
And we're seeing how
essentially bringing the artwork
on a place like the boardwalk
is allowing a deeper interaction
with them.
And I think the audience
is really responding really
well to this kind of work,
like the "Formatives" piece.
EMILY FORTUNA: Alex
and Kenric, thank
you so much for sharing
and making this happen.
It's really a lovely
place to hang out.
ALEX CZETWERTYNSKI: Thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hey, guys!
AUDIENCE: Hey!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Emily.
On this end of
the boardwalk, I'm
joined by former attorney,
human rights activist,
and inclusive
designer, Alex Roy.
Lisa, thanks for
coming to I/O Live.
ELISE ROY: Thanks
for having me here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For those that
don't know your back story,
you lost your hearing at age 10.
ELISE ROY: I did.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Which is why we're
going to be using
Google's live transcribe
app to make our conversation
happen in real time?
Can you tell us what it means
to be an inclusive designer?
ELISE ROY: Absolutely.
So an inclusive
designer is someone
that helps organizations
solve problems
from the perspective of
people with disabilities
or difference.
It's based on this
human-centered design tenet
that when we solve
for extremes, we often
develop better solutions
than we solve for average.
And that might seem kind
of counterintuitive,
because the greatest
number of people
tend to hover around average.
But the problem is that no
one actually is average.
And so when we solve
for average, then--
and people are a little bit
over here, a little bit there--
there's this gap
between what we create
and what their needs are
that we're not meeting.
If instead we solve
for those extremes,
then we've already
covered that gap
and we've created
something that's
a lot more adaptable and
a lot more innovative.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
makes so much sense to me.
And it reminds me
of something else
that you've talked about,
which is human-centered design.
Can you define that
term for us, as well?
ELISE ROY: Sure.
So human-centered design is
a philosophy, a methodology
for problem solving.
It's based on a lot
of things that we've
taken from the design room.
And it can be applied to almost
every realm you could imagine
from international development,
to privacy, to the sciences,
to technology.
And what differentiates it is
it's almost obsessive focus
on designing around the human
that we're trying to reach.
So in the past a lot
of times we think
that when we're trying
to solve a problem,
we want to get all the
experts into this room
and have them figure
out how to solve it.
The problem with
that is they have
one point of view, their own.
So if, for example, they're
a bunch of developers,
they're probably going to create
something that's very complex
and most of us, the
so-called average people,
don't really understand.
If instead we focus our
process on the people
we're trying to reach, then
we develop something that
fits their needs much better.
And so there's a lot
of empathy involved,
where you're trying
to understand
what their needs are.
You're following them around
in real life situations.
You want to make
sure that you're also
answering the right problem.
So many people are
answering the wrong problem.
And then there's ideation, which
is similar to brainstorming,
but we use a lot
of design methods
to really get people
thinking outside the box.
It's a lot more powerful.
We want people to do
a lot of crazy ideas.
We want as many as
they can think of.
And then we prototype,
which is a low fi
solution that we
know we're going
to mess up with, you know?
But that's the purpose of it is
to fail and to learn from it.
And then the last step is to
implement it and make sure
that it's sustainable.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I love this
idea of having practices
and mechanisms for
helping experts get out
of their perspective.
Because when you bring
an expert in the room,
you're asking them to give
their expert opinion, not
their general opinion.
And that's so focused
most of the time, right?
ELISE ROY: Exactly, exactly--
that's also why I
love inclusive design.
Because that brings people
even further outside
of their tunnel vision.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This reminds
me of another quote of yours,
if I may, you said, "When we
look for gaps of exclusion,
we identify opportunities
for great change."
And I find this
really inspiring.
Do you have some examples
that you can share where
you see this really clearly?
ELISE ROY: Definitely--
I can give you some
Google-centric examples.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
ELISE ROY: So Google's Chief
Internet evangelist Vint Cert,
he created email
for his deaf wife.
And as you know, that's become a
huge thing that everyone loves.
But he didn't see
it as something
that would be applied
to everyone initially.
And most people didn't think
of it in that way at first.
Because we had the capabilities
to talk to people on the phone.
And that was the way
that business was run.
But slowly, we realized
that people also
have this desire to not
have to keep talking
to someone on the phone.
And they want to say something
real quick and be done with it.
And sometimes we
also have this desire
to formulate our thoughts before
we communicate with someone.
And email fills
those hidden desires.
Another example is YouTube.
They inserted closed captioning
capabilities into their media
player, which was really
amazing at the time.
And closed captioning was
originally created for the deaf
so that they could follow along.
But what YouTube realized was
that if a video has closed
captioning capabilities,
then the likelihood
of it being watched to the
end was increased by 80%.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Wow.
ELISE ROY: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is that because
there's so many situations
where you have the sound off?
ELISE ROY: Exactly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
ELISE ROY: So the reason why
designing for inclusion works
is because we find ourselves,
as we go about our lives,
in these momentary
situations where
we have a momentary disability.
So we might be
carrying something,
and we lose the use of our arms.
If we're in a bar,
closed captioning
is helpful because
we can't hear.
And if we are in
our office, and we
want to sneak in a Facebook
video, captioning is helpful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So that's awesome.
Those are really great examples.
And I love how it's
really connecting
this idea of designing
for the extremes
and then it becomes more
usable for everyone.
ELISE ROY: Exactly, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It's really great.
Elise, thank you so much
for joining us and sharing
your gifts and your insights.
I really appreciate it.
ELISE ROY: Thank you
so much for having me.
I really appreciate it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
It's time for another break.
Because the next sessions
are about to begin.
You're watching I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Welcome
back to I/O Live,
your ticket to an
insider's view of I/O'19.
I'm Emily Fortuna.
If you like games, you're going
to enjoy what's coming next.
Let's send it over Todd for a
look at the mega hamster demo.
AUDIENCE: Hey!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BACKGROUND CONVERSATIONS]
TODD KERPELMAN: I am here at
the gaming garage with Darren
Hilton checking out what is sure
to be the next great big game,
Mega Hamster.
Hi, Darren.
DARREN HILTON: Hi, Todd.
How are you doing?
TODD KERPELMAN: Good.
Now the last time
I saw Mega Hamster,
it did not have this
multiplayer component
that I'm seeing
going on behind me.
What's going on here?
DARREN HILTON: So this is a
project that we did with Cloud.
And so we decided to incorporate
the Agones and Open Match
open source projects
into Mega Hamster.
TODD KERPELMAN: What are those?
Start with Open Match.
DARREN HILTON: So Open Match
is a framework for connecting
clients to our game servers.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
Meaning that if you've got
a bunch of players that
want to play a
multiplayer game together,
I would use Open Match
to help connect them
based on what kind of criteria.
DARREN HILTON: Based on the
criteria that you lay out,
their skill level,
that kind of thing.
You can go in and kind of dig
in and give that criteria.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
that kind of helps
solve the problem
of finding people
that actually want to play--
DARREN HILTON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: --with
maybe the same skill level.
DARREN HILTON: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Or in
the same general area,
have good network latency.
DARREN HILTON: Exactly, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Excellent.
DARREN HILTON: You don't want
to have that experience where
you have low level players
being connected with high level
players and then getting
a bad game experience.
TODD KERPELMAN:
And then Agones--
what is that?
DARREN HILTON: So Agones is
a multiplayer gaming server
application that's
built on Kubernetes.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And so I know there's a lot
of multiplayer game servers
out there.
What makes Agones special?
DARREN HILTON: So Agones is
special in that it can scale
to the needs of your game.
So if you wanted to add
thousands of servers--
TODD KERPELMAN: You mean,
when Mega Hamster becomes
a mega hit, we got millions and
Millions of people playing it.
DARREN HILTON: And we totally
expect that to happen.
TODD KERPELMAN: Of course.
DARREN HILTON: It's
going to happen.
The other thing, too, is
that it's cloud agnostic.
It's an open source project.
You can run it on any
cloud service you want.
You can run it locally.
You could run it on frame
on your own service.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
And so because it's
based on Kubernetes,
it can scale to sort of--
DARREN HILTON: It can scale.
TODD KERPELMAN:
--basically, until I
run out of servers or until
Google runs out of servers,
which is going to take a while.
DARREN HILTON: Exactly.
And everything you
need for that server
is contained in that
Kubernetes container.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
And so now, with a dedicated
game server like Agones,
I know sometimes in multiplayer
games, particularly mobile
ones, you'll have the
clients talking to each other
directly in a
peer-to-peer network.
What makes a dedicated
game server better?
DARREN HILTON: So the
dedicated game server
gives you the added level
of security and that--
that's [INAUDIBLE] truth.
And the scalability's
another thing.
So you can scale to
however you want it to,
scale to meet the
needs of your game.
And a peer-to-peer network is
relatively limited in that,
generally limited to a
smaller amount of clients.
TODD KERPELMAN: You can't
have 100 clients all talking--
DARREN HILTON: You
can't have 100 clients.
TODD KERPELMAN:
--that would just--
that poor one client that's
acting as your server
for that episode.
DARREN HILTON: Somebody
could mess with that.
It could lose it's game state.
You know, there's a lot of
things can go wrong with that.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
I'm guessing latency is probably
more likely to be consistent,
because you're not
relying on that one client
to be the server
for the entire game.
DARREN HILTON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
All right.
And then I couldn't
help but notice
you're wearing a very
stylish Firebase t-shirt.
So Firebase is integrated
in this game, as well.
DARREN HILTON: Exactly.
So we're using a bunch
of Firebase products.
We're using authentication,
cloud messaging, remote config,
real time database,
and Crashlytics.
TODD KERPELMAN:
Oh, Crashlytics--
that's new, right?
DARREN HILTON: New as of GDC.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
And is this running on Unity?
DARREN HILTON: It's
running on Unity.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
so now Crashlytics
for Unity will actually
let me, as a developer,
find out if there are
crashes in my game
and where they're happening.
DARREN HILTON: Exactly.
So you can go through,
find your stack trace,
and then narrow in on the bugs
that are affecting your game.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
And have you found lots of
crashes in Mega Hamster?
DARREN HILTON: Of course not.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well,
of course, [INAUDIBLE]..
Because it is solid code.
DARREN HILTON: Rock solid.
TODD KERPELMAN: Rock solid
code that never crashes.
And with remote
config, I know one
of the fun things
of remote config,
especially as a game
developer, if you
find some level is too hard or
some setting is too difficult,
you can basically
kind of tweak that.
And all your clients get
to get updated on the fly.
DARREN HILTON: You
can turn that, yeah.
And you can roll out
to all your clients,
or you can roll out to a
segment of players, as well.
TODD KERPELMAN: Like sort
of running an A/B test?
DARREN HILTON: Yeah, exactly.
You can test that.
And if it's stable, then you can
roll up to everyone, as well.
TODD KERPELMAN: If I wanted to
try out Mega Hamster at home,
how would I be able to do that?
DARREN HILTON: You can
download the single player game
from the Play Store
or from the app store.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
And last question,
were any hamsters
harmed in the making
of Mega Hamster?
DARREN HILTON: I believe not.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well, that's always
good to hear.
And with that, we're
going to take you over
to Page Bailey, who's going
to tell you more about how
to make your apps better.
So take it away, Page.
PAIGE BAILEY: Thanks
so much, Todd.
I'm Paige Bailey, a
TensorFlow developer advocate.
And I'm here today with
Doug Stevenson, who
is going to tell us
all about the latest
and greatest in Firebase.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
PAIGE BAILEY: So show us
what you have planned, Doug.
DOUG STEVENSON: OK.
So turns out
Firebase has a bunch
of products that help you ensure
high quality of your app, which
is very important for a
lot of app developers.
Every app developer always has
to be able to diagnose crashes
in their app--
PAIGE BAILEY: Yes.
DOUG STEVENSON: --as you know.
So Firebase has a tool
called Crashlytics.
With Crashlytics, the
integration is fairly simple.
Add a plug-in.
Add a build dependency
to your build.
And it just starts
monitoring crashes.
You don't have to write
any lines of code.
So the app is crashing.
You can see that it's rather
problematic for our users.
But it turns out the engineers
made a good decision,
and they put this new
home screen experiment
behind a remote config flag.
PAIGE BAILEY: So tell
me a little bit more
about what remote config is.
DOUG STEVENSON: Right.
So remote config lets you
define key value pairs
in the Firebase console.
And then you can publish
those to your app
without having to actually write
any lines of code in your app.
So it gets them all,
almost immediately,
as you change them
in the console.
So the idea here is we
have a new parameter.
It's called home screen
experiment enabled.
And the default value is true.
So this is what's enabling the
new home screen experiment.
That's also causing
devices to crash.
Now what we want to do
here is ask our engineer.
And so our engineer thinks
that it's a translation issue.
So we've narrowed it down
to Spanish speakers who
are using the app on Android.
So we can define a new
condition here for this flag
and say, for
Spanish speakers who
are using Android, what
we can do is disable
the home screen experiment.
So we'll set it to
false for all of them,
and all the other users
can retain the value true.
So now once this is
configured, what we'll do
is publish this to our app.
And the app, internally, will
use Firebase remote config
to fetch parameters, pull
out that home screen flag,
and enable the home
screen experiment if it's
been enabled for this device.
PAIGE BAILEY: And it's
amazing that you're
able to narrow in with
such laser focus what
the problem could be, and then
to change it without altering
a single line of code.
DOUG STEVENSON: Right.
Right.
So it's remotely fixing
your app, in some cases.
And we do recommend that
people publish their apps
with new features hidden
behind remote config flags
so you can toggle them on
and off for cases like this.
PAIGE BAILEY: Right.
DOUG STEVENSON: So we'll
publish our new changes
to remote config.
We can see that the app
is no longer crashing.
PAIGE BAILEY: I see
no more sad faces.
DOUG STEVENSON: No
more sad faces--
and the number of crash
free users has gone up.
So we've reduced the crash
rate down to below 1%,
which is really good-- so
a successful experiment.
PAIGE BAILEY: That's amazing.
So launch into the next demo.
What do we have next?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
So another thing that
developers need to be able to do
is compare what
their users prefer.
PAIGE BAILEY: A/B testing.
DOUG STEVENSON: Perform an A/B
test, yes-- so what we can do
is use Firebase A/B testing to
create and run an experiment.
So what we can do
in the console here
is create an
experiment with a name,
targeting half of our
users with some metrics
that we want to track.
And we're going to use
Firebase remote config again
to configure this experiment.
So for the control group,
dark mode will not be enabled.
And for the variant group, we
will enable this experiment.
So remote config
is going to tell
half the devices to
run this experiment
and have the devices not.
And we'll compare the metrics
on that and see how it performs.
PAIGE BAILEY: And all of this
is done through the console?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yes, all of this
is done through the console.
So we can see here our
experiment is ready to run.
We're especially interested
in 15 day retentions.
So we're going to use that
as the way to determine
whether or not this
experiment is successful.
So what we can do is
start this experiment.
Bear in mind that
remote config is
being used to pull
out that Boolean flag
and enable dark mode
only for those half
of all devices that are
configured to use it.
And what we're going to
do is run this A/B test.
And that's going to
push to our devices.
And you can see some of our
devices are running dark mode,
and some are running
light mode, and they're
switching between the two.
PAIGE BAILEY: I think I
like the light mode best.
DOUG STEVENSON:
You like the light?
OK.
I'm partial to dark mode.
But--
PAIGE BAILEY: Well, let's
see what the users say.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
The users get to decide
based on our goal metrics.
PAIGE BAILEY: Oh, man.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
It looks like dark mode
is the leader in this.
And we can see the exact
mark on the retention
that this experiment had.
PAIGE BAILEY: This is amazing.
I was a data scientist
in a previous life.
And historically,
we would have to use
weeks of training and custom
code and configurations
and track all of the metrics
and visualizations ourselves.
But this, looks
like you could do it
just by clicking
a couple buttons.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yes, an
entire engine is basically
hidden by Firebase A/B testing.
So we can use remote
config, and then push it out
to all of our users.
All right.
The last thing that a
lot of app developers
are concerned about--
PAIGE BAILEY: And probably
the most important one.
DOUG STEVENSON:
--yeah, and everyone
wants their pages to load fast,
and their screens to be snappy.
So what we can do is measure
that with Firebase Performance
Monitoring.
Now with Firebase
Performance Monitoring,
you put basically
one SDK in your app
and it automatically
collects things.
And it goes out to
your users and it
measures the behavior of your
app on your user's devices.
But if you do need
to measure something
in particular, like, say,
the load screen time, what
you can do is create a trace.
PAIGE BAILEY: And so
tell me what a trace is?
DOUG STEVENSON: Ah, yeah.
So a trace is something in
Firebase Performance Monitoring
that measures the
duration of something.
So here we're
creating a new trace.
We're starting a timer.
Then after we load all of our
image and text for this screen,
we'll stop the timer.
That becomes our metric.
So that's going to get sent
to the Firebase Performance
Monitoring dashboard.
So we're going to run this code
on all of our users' devices,
collect this metric.
And now what you can see
here is the trend over time
is that 555 milliseconds
of load time.
PAIGE BAILEY: That
is way too long.
DOUG STEVENSON:
It's half a second,
but it still feels
like an eternity when
you click the button.
So what we need to do
is bring this down.
Now it turns out this
app's been configured
with Firebase remote config
to have a configurable image
quality.
So the idea is to speed up
the performance for our app,
we'll ratchet down the quality.
Maybe that will make the images
smaller and faster to load.
So what we can do is
create a condition for this
and say that half of our
users get a reduced quality.
So when we finalize
this, half of our users
are going to get the
default and the other half
are going to get this
reduced image quality.
And then we can compare
this in the dashboard.
Now again, we do need
a few lines of code
to enable this in remote config.
When that's done, we can collect
this information on our users
devices exactly as they're using
it and come up with results.
So we were able to reduce
the time to 111 milliseconds.
And our engineer thinks
this is a good idea.
PAIGE BAILEY: Much faster--
and I agree with them.
And it also looks like you
can drill down into the data
by device?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
So right now, we're slicing
this by app version.
But you can also use
other characteristics
of the device and
the user to determine
what the performance is for
very specific conditions.
PAIGE BAILEY: That's amazing.
And I love being able to see
the visualizations just out
of the box.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
PAIGE BAILEY: So thank
you so much for sharing
all of this great
functionality with Firebase.
I can't wait to try
out an A/B test.
DOUG STEVENSON:
Thanks for joining me.
PAIGE BAILEY: Absolutely.
Thank you so much.
And back to you.
EMILY FORTUNA: The
sandbox is a great place
to check out a huge range
of new tech and hardware.
Coming up later
in the show, we'll
take you back to the sandbox
and highlight even more demos.
You won't want to miss it.
But first a quick break.
And after the next
session, we'll
see you back here
for more I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Welcome
back to I/O Live.
If you missed any
part of the festival,
catch up at g.co/io/live.
EMILY FORTUNA: Timothy, how
was the festival last night?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It was awesome.
We went exploring.
Check it out.
SPEAKER 1: Hey, Timothy!
We should go to After Dark.
I want to go dancing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What?
SPEAKER 1: I want to go dancing!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Let's do it!
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm an enormous space nerd.
Do you have anything
space themed?
SPEAKER 2: We have
an awesome space ship
tattoo that's really cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm in.
SPEAKER 3: I could
do that right here.
Is that cool?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: Oww!
SPEAKER 3: We're going to
put our unicorn on there.
SPEAKER 1: We got a unicorn!
Oh, OK.
So it says eats over there
and there's hopefully--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, yeah.
You hungry?
SPEAKER 1: --the
cones of [INAUDIBLE]..
There's advice?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Let's do it.
AUDIENCE: What you do is
you can ask her a question.
SPEAKER 1: What will I
have for lunch tomorrow?
So, like, I think
I want a salad.
But I really want pizza.
SPEAKER 5: Hello!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a little dusty up here.
SPEAKER 5: [SQUEALING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It won't come off!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I don't know.
This might be my new job.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER 1: Timothy, thank you
so much for hanging out with me
during my first I/O after dark.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Are you kidding?
This was tons of fun.
I mean, this is what makes
it a developer festival.
EMILY FORTUNA: That
looked like a lot of fun.
If you're here on
site, you'll definitely
want to check out after
dark before you head home.
Now let's check in with
Todd for an AR sandbox
demo that is out of this world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN:
Hello, I/O viewers--
well, what better
way to follow up
an interview with a
real life astronaut
than to check out a
virtual spaceship?
So I am here with Amanda in
the augmented reality booth.
And you're going to show me
something cool from the NASA
website.
AMANDA LE: Yeah.
So here you can see on the
NASA website they're showing
3D models of their Rovers.
Here we have the
Curiosity Rover.
And they're actually using
the model VR web component
to put that 3D asset
on their website.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
That's very cool.
Now you said it's
a web component.
So do they need to like
NPM install something
to get it working?
AMANDA LE: It's actually
a mark up, so very simple
to just put on your website.
TODD KERPELMAN: I gotcha.
Well, that's very cool.
And this 3D model, what
file format is that?
AMANDA LE: So we
recommend using GLTF.
But it also supports
USDZ and GLB.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
And is that something most
commercial 3D modeling
tools will export to?
AMANDA LE: You should be
able to export to that.
TODD KERPELMAN: I see you've got
that little button down there
in the bottom right.
What does that do?
AMANDA LE: So this
actually is the new feature
that we're launching
at I/O today.
And what it allows you
to do is open up what
we call Scene Viewer.
So Scene Viewer allows
you to take this 3D model
and actually place it in
your real world space.
TODD KERPELMAN: Whoa.
No way!
AMANDA LE: So here you can see
the Curiosity Rover at scale.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
It's like there's a real live
spaceship here in the booth,
but not really.
It's just actually
very nicely rendered.
And it kind of fooled me.
AMANDA LE: Yep.
And so you can
actually manipulate
this in your own space.
So you'll see it at full scale.
But you can also shrink it
down so that it can actually
fit in your living room.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
Yes.
So if I want to put the
Curiosity Rover on my coffee
table, I now can, just by
shrinking it down a little bit.
AMANDA LE: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so how did
you get the size specification?
Apparently this was
built real life,
or this is showing
it in real life,
and you're able
to shrink it down?
AMANDA LE: Yeah.
So NASA, when they
built the 3D model,
decided to build it at scale.
So that's the model
we're referencing.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
Very cool.
And so if I'm a
developer and I want
to turn my model
via your component
into this cool Scene Viewer
augmented reality experience,
what do I have to do?
AMANDA LE: Yeah.
So there's no need to
build an app for this.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
AMANDA LE: All you actually
do is going into the mark up.
And you add the AR
attribute, which
is literally the letters A and
R. So it's super simple to do.
TODD KERPELMAN: I type two
letters and I get all that?
AMANDA LE: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well, that sounds easy.
I think even I could do that.
AMANDA LE: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well,
I can use a little
pick me up after that demo.
Let's head on over here and see
if I can find some caffeine!
Woo!
Hey, Ashish.
ASHISH SHAH: How
are you doing, Todd?
TODD KERPELMAN: I am doing well.
I'm already excited
for this demo,
because I see there's an
espresso machine here.
So walk me [INAUDIBLE].
ASHISH SHAH: All right.
So what we're
doing here is we're
showing an espresso machine
coming to life in AR
using this technology called
augmented images that's part of
[INAUDIBLE].
You want to give it a spin?
TODD KERPELMAN:
Let's check it out.
ASHISH SHAH: All right.
So as soon as you
look at this marker--
TODD KERPELMAN: So you're
showing the image there.
ASHISH SHAH: Yep.
TODD KERPELMAN: And it's
telling you to look around.
ASHISH SHAH: And now it's
annotated the machine
with information
about its features.
See the little--
TODD KERPELMAN: Is
this coming to life?
ASHISH SHAH: --yep.
It's telling you about
dose control, grinding.
TODD KERPELMAN: I need
my doses controlled.
ASHISH SHAH: And the
precise temperature--
what would you do without that?
And you can actually see an
espresso being made here.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, fantastic.
ASHISH SHAH: This is a really
powerful way for manufacturers
to show features
of their product,
which are otherwise
just lost in text.
This really makes the
product come to life--
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
ASHISH SHAH: --in a
really powerful way.
And so this triggers the
experience, once it recognizes.
And now what happens once
this image is recognized,
it starts establishing
a correspondence
between the phone and the image.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
the phone always
knows exactly where it is--
ASHISH SHAH: With
respect to the image--
and when I say it establishes
a correspondence in terms
[INAUDIBLE],, that's
position and orientation.
So position in like x
direction and y direction
and in z direction, and also the
orientation in three degrees,
like pitch, yaw, and roll.
So the phone knows
exactly where it
is with respect to the marker.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
So this kind of
works best in places
where you sort of have strict
control over the environment
in which this image is going
to appear and what's around it?
ASHISH SHAH: Yes.
If you're trying to
augment real things,
you want to make sure
that the image is
rigid with respect to the thing
that you're trying to augment.
TODD KERPELMAN: Gotcha.
ASHISH SHAH: But
if you just want
the image itself
specifically to come to life,
that's all you need [INAUDIBLE].
ASHISH SHAH: Absolutely.
So think about a scenario
where you're at a store,
and you want to see
what's inside a box.
So you could use an
app to look at the box.
It would recognize
the box as a marker,
and you could actually
have a sneak peek
at what's inside the box.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh.
OK.
So the model could
pop out of the box.
ASHISH SHAH: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: And I can
see exactly what my waffle
iron or toaster--
I need stuff in my kitchen--
that's all going to look like.
ASHISH SHAH: Without
even opening it,
without even opening it up.
TODD KERPELMAN: And then I won't
get yelled at by shopkeepers.
ASHISH SHAH: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, thank
you very much, Ashish.
I learned a lot about
augmented reality today.
I'm going to grab this espresso.
Oh, it's not real.
But the coffee beans are.
Can I eat the coffee beans?
ASHISH SHAH: Yes.
You can.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm going to
take a few coffee beans to go.
ASHISH SHAH: I think you can
take the coffee beans, Todd.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thank you
very much, livestream.
I'm going to go get caffeinated.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Todd.
Got a comment about our AR
sandbox or anything else
you've seen on the show?
Make sure to share
it using #I/O'19.
Also here's a quick shout
out to the more than 500
extended viewing parties
from 60 countries
joining us on the Livestream.
AUDIENCE: Hi from I/O
[INAUDIBLE] Boulder.
ASHISH SHAH: This is Google
Seattle's I/O extended.
Hey, everybody!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great to
have you along for the ride.
Time for us to take a
break as the next sessions
will begin shortly.
We'll be back in about an
hour with more sandbox demos.
You're watching I/O live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Welcome
back to I/O Live.
I'm Emily Fortuna.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
I'm Timothy Jordan.
We're joined by special
guests Eve Ekman,
Director of Training at the
Greater Good Science Center
at UC Berkeley, and
Collaborator William
Russell, creative
director of Monom Berlin's
Center for Spatial Sound.
Welcome, both of you.
It's great to have you here.
WILLIAM RUSSELL:
Great to be here.
EVE EKMAN: Yeah, thanks.
EMILY FORTUNA: So
tell me-- you've
created this really excellent
art installation here
at Google I/O. Why make it here?
EVE EKMAN: Yeah.
So I was really fortunate.
William's artistic vision
wanted to build upon a project
that my dad and I
had collaborated
on about three years ago.
And this was an
atlas of emotion.
The inspiration for this came
from His Holiness, the Dalai
Lama, who is so
passionate about all of us
finding our way to a calm mind.
He thought maybe we
need a map to get there.
So the idea was to take the best
of what we know from emotion
research and create
a way for people
to actually visualize emotion.
And then, here at I/O,
we are giving people
an opportunity to know what
it's like to experience emotion.
So it seems so simple to
be aware of our emotions.
And yet, for most
of us, we avoid,
suppress, deny anything that
doesn't feel good, which
actually doesn't help
us understand ourselves
or understand others.
So this is just one more
portal and way for people
to get into these ideas of
emotion awareness, well-being,
empathy, connection,
and compassion.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
sounds really powerful.
William, could you
describe the work?
What is it going to
be like for those
of us that can't be there?
WILLIAM RUSSELL: Yeah.
Well, the piece is being created
using a sound technology built
by 4D sound.
So the experience is there's
about 85 speakers spread
out evenly throughout the room.
And the idea is that it
creates sounds more naturally,
more the way that we perceive
them in the real world, how
we've evolved to
perceive them, which
allows us to connect more deeply
to people's awareness of sound
and how this interacts
with their body.
But the idea in this
piece is actually
we have artist
Amanda Gregory, who
will be singing and
sort of theatrically
performing and
controlling elements
of the sound in the space,
as well as being triggered
by the soundscape
that is around her.
So the idea is she's
actually, in real time,
trying to embody
as much as possible
the experience around
her and respond to this
and just be fully open and
aware to her emotional landscape
at the time through
this natural sounds,
but also tones and
frequencies that we've learned
have certain effects on
the emotional awareness,
essentially.
There is an area
of universal things
that we're finding that
do stimulate generally
everyone in a similar way.
But then there's a mysterious,
other, more complex world
that we're looking forward
to explore further, as well.
Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
idea of paying attention
to our emotions and
understanding those triggering
states I think is really
relevant to us and our audience
in software development.
We were talking a little
earlier about this,
and I think it's
really interesting,
that software development
of any sufficient complexity
requires lots of people.
And therefore, the most
interesting software problems
are actually people problems.
And a lot of that dynamic
is governed by our emotions,
how we react with each other,
how we react with, like,
this big thing that we're
all trying to do together.
And I think in that way,
it's really important for us
to study emotional intelligence.
And that's, I think,
why I'm really excited
about this work being here.
EVE EKMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
I completely agree.
And you know, I've been a
trained emotion scientist,
maybe, since I was born.
Since my dad is the
founder of this field,
Paul Ekman, and really
mapped the human face.
So how do we recognize
the universal language
of what I'm showing you right
now, so anger versus I'm
feeling really good.
And when we can understand how
to interpret these signals,
we have a lot of capacity
for clear communication.
We are born with this skill--
not only to read faces, but
to ourselves kind of show
what we're feeling.
And then, as William was
saying, at an embodied level,
we resonate to the
emotions of others.
So even if you're
trying your hardest,
actually this project,
for this team,
we don't need emotions here.
We just gotta be efficient.
Good luck!
We are hardwired head
to toe for emotion.
We absolutely have
no control over what
triggers us emotionally.
We have some capacity
to recognize, OK,
I'm feeling frustrated,
annoyed, or anxious,
and then respond
more constructively.
So the whole goal with
emotional intelligence
isn't to change from lots
of emotions to no emotions.
It's to understand
and identify what
is the message this
emotion is telling you
and then respond in a way
that's the most effective.
And really, that's constructive.
And really, that's empathy.
Right?
That is an ability to recognize
what's happening to another
and then identify what's
the best response.
This is a core value of humans.
And without it, we wouldn't
have survived as a species.
So how do we harness that
for creativity, productivity,
and engagement?
EMILY FORTUNA: So I
think you've already
gotten a little bit at this.
But if there's
one thing that you
hope that attendees or
viewers would take away
from your work in future, the
general trend of your future
work, what would it be?
EVE EKMAN: Yeah.
I bet we both have a
different response.
I think I would be
really excited for people
to become deeply interested
in their emotions.
And not at a
I'm-going-to-fix-this, thinking
way, but oh, my gosh.
My emotions exist in my body.
When I feel angry, there's
tightness in my jaw
and constriction in my chest.
And when I feel anxious, wow,
there's some like shoulder.
And just that
level of awareness,
what we call a meta awareness
or metacognitive awareness
means you have some space
away from the experience
and you might not be
quite so reactive.
EMILY FORTUNA: And William?
WILLIAM RUSSELL: I mean, I
mean, I agree with all of that.
But the idea is that we want
to create these experiences so
that they can feel these
things as deeply as possible
and to really be
able to learn them
through the use of
their whole body.
Because the idea is not that
there's good or bad emotions.
They're equal to each other.
They all have their role.
And for me, this has been
an incredible learning
process that's just beginning.
I mean, this is experiment one.
So I'm learning a lot
from Eve about what
is the real science
that we have and what
is still to be explored.
And I think this is going to be
a constantly evolving process.
I mean, it came from a
discussion between the Dalai
Lama and Paul Ekman originally.
And it will continue
to be a discussion,
because this is such a
rich territory to explore.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
William, Eve, thank you
so much for being here.
We really appreciate it.
And thank you for your work.
EVE EKMAN: Yeah, and
I just really want
to think whatever mastermind
behind this conference
wanted to do AI for good.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
EVE EKMAN: I mean, as a
representative of the Greater
Good Science Center, of
course I believe in that.
But I think it's so nice to
infuse this experience with how
technology can help us and
really support us in being
the humans we want to be.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Now let's check in
with our sandbox
team for more demos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi.
I'm Wayne Piekarski.
And I'm here today at
the Assistant sandbox
area of Google I/O 2019.
And we're in the
smart home area.
And I have Carl Vogel here
from the product team.
And what we're going to
be talking about today
is smart home and
what it means and what
it means for developers.
So Carl, what is
the developer story?
And what is smart
home all about?
CARL VOGEL: Smart home
is a way for users
to control all the connected
devices in their house,
everything from smart lights
and smart thermostats to even
smart plugs-- and even
vacuum cleaners, now.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK.
Cool.
So I mean, what does
it mean for developers?
Can anyone build
for the smart home?
CARL VOGEL: Exactly.
So we have over a
3,500 brands that
go ahead and integrate
with Google Assistant
and are growing rapidly.
Anyone can go into the
Actions on Google console
and integrate
their smart devices
into Google Assistant such
that users can control them
with just the Assistant
and their voice.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK, cool.
So this year, at Google
I/O 2019, [INAUDIBLE]
announced local home SDK.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So
what's that about,
and what's new for
developers and why are they
interested in this?
CARL VOGEL: This is great.
So developers today integrate
with the Google Assistant
via the smart home API, which
is a cloud to cloud integration.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK.
CARL VOGEL: And cloud
to cloud integrations
naturally have some amount
of latency and reliability.
So we want to provide
a method for developers
to process those smart
home intents locally
on Google home speakers and
Google [INAUDIBLE] such that we
can turn on and off the lights
and other things much faster
and with higher reliability.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
We do it directly,
by skipping the
cloud, basically.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah.
We skip that developers cloud.
And they can replicate their
business logic there and run it
on our device.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK.
Well, what excites
me the most is
that here at I/O, we
have this fantastic
demo that we've built.
CARL VOGEL: It's a great demo.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So we have
this great train set here
that's designed to demonstrate
local versus cloud execution.
So I guess-- well,
there's this button here
that I really want to press.
CARL VOGEL: Give me one
second if I can, Wayne.
So what we're looking at is
this is the local network.
And this is the
internet once the query
leaves the user's home.
We have the life
of a local query
and a life of a cloud query.
So with that, go ahead
and push the button.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So we're
going to race some trains here.
They're going to go around,
and then these light bulbs
are going to come on
when they're done.
OK.
Here we go.
CARL VOGEL: So here we
have the user saying,
turn on the lights.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK.
CARL VOGEL: And we
see these two queries
going to the Assistant server.
And they're both going to be
processed in the same way.
And via the smart home
API, they go ahead
and we send that to the partner
cloud or developer cloud, where
they go ahead and
process that intent,
and ultimately,
then, fulfill it.
If we know the device
is locally controllable,
then we'll send that
command back down
to the Google home device,
where we'll then pull up
the developer's JavaScript
to process that intent, where
they can communicate with their
light, and look, turn it on.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: This one's
still coming by the cloud.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah.
It's still coming in.
It's going to get there.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: There we go.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah.
So what this does again, it
highlights the reduced latency
that we can get with the local
home SDK and local operations.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Well, this is awesome.
I really love this train set.
I've always loved trains
since I was a kid.
So this was a really fun demo.
So where can developers
go to learn more
about the local home SDK?
CARL VOGEL: Yeah.
go.co/localhomeSDK
is our landing page.
We also are giving
a talk Wednesday
at 5:30 PM called "Local
Technologies for the Smart
Home."
So if you're interested,
check it out and learn more.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: And it's
also on YouTube, as well.
So people--
CARL VOGEL: Exactly.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Awesome.
Well, thanks for
your time, Carl.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah.
Thanks, Wayne.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: And thanks
for watching the video.
This was the Assistant
sandbox area.
So we'll see you next time.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thanks, team.
If you want to check
out any part of I/O,
go to g.co/io/live.
After these next
sessions, Ted Haas
will join us on set for a
conversation on Android.
And we've got more
from our sandbox.
You won't want to miss it.
You're watching I/O Live from
the heart of Silicon Valley.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Welcome back.
Our final guest of
the day is Chet Haase.
Whom you already know if
you're an Android developer.
Though you might not
know that he's also
the author of "Round and Holy--
An Homage to Donuts."
Chet, welcome to the show.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
we already talked
with Dan Galpin about
all the announcements
that were in the keynotes.
CHET HAASE: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
I'm hoping that we can
go kind of more big picture.
Is that OK?
CHET HAASE: You're saying,
you're saying fast forward.
Don't talk about that
stuff we already heard.
You're boring me.
That's what I'm hearing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I mean, I
wouldn't have put it that way.
CHET HAASE: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Anyway, Kotlin first.
CHET HAASE: Kotlin first.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
What does that mean?
And sort of, like,
how do we get here
and what does it mean for
developers moving forward?
CHET HAASE: Sure.
So--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Big picture.
CHET HAASE: Big picture--
so the big picture is
we announced Kotlin
a couple of years ago.
It turns out people
really like it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's good.
CHET HAASE: A lot of developers
really liked it at that time
anyway.
What we announced was, yeah,
we understand you like it,
and we're going to support
it as an official language.
So it's a good thing.
So people continued to
use it more and more.
We agree with everyone.
They should be using
it more and more.
And now we want to invest
in it more and more
and offer more capabilities for
them to use it more and more.
You like that phrase?
I like it a lot.
I'm using it a lot.
So let me give you a
couple of examples.
So we have this set of
APIs called Jetpack.
And increasing a
lot of the stuff
that we're doing
in Jetpack, instead
of including some of the stuff
that's coming out at I/O,
it's going to be coming out
first with Kotlin capabilities,
things like co-routine
integration into a room,
also co-routing deep integration
into lifecycle and live data
to make things easier.
Kotlin only-- or
Kotlin first library
is like the new Jetpack
composed that we just
announced we're going to be
developing in the open today.
So we're going to be
doing much more Kotlin
stuff for Kotlin developers
outside of Android, as well.
We're also investing in
more training and docs
and sample code, things,
like, see, with JetBrains,
we're doing Kotlin everywhere.
It's this global
series of events,
conference-type
educational events.
There's also a new
Udacity course.
I think it's developing Android
applications with Kotlin.
Just launched all of those
episodes in that course.
So just a lot more training
in general to help people
learn and use Kotlin
more, because we think
they should be doing that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think one
of the interesting discoveries
I made the other day is that
there are developers now
that started as Kotlin
Android developers.
CHET HAASE: That blows my mind.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right?
Which is-- anyway, that's cool.
You've been on Android
for a while now.
And--
CHET HAASE: Oh, I was
supposed to fill that in.
So I joined, actually,
nine years ago this month.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: 9 years?
CHET HAASE: Yeah, 2010.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Sometime-- in that time,
I'm sure had a really unique
perspective on everything
that's happened in the
developer space for Android.
So here's two relatively
specific questions for you.
One, what's something that's
super exceptional that you
didn't expect when you
started working on Android?
And what's something
that you still
want to make better,
after all this time?
CHET HAASE: So
super exceptional--
there's a bunch of
things to choose from.
There's all kinds of
interesting features.
And development
software is cool,
because new stuff
happens all the time.
I'm going to pick
Jetpack, because I
feel very close to this.
Because a lot of that work
was coming out of the team
that I was working
with, the toolkit team.
Where we had all
these capabilities
in support library--
the worst thing about
support library--
we called it support
library, but it was actually
a plural set of libraries.
So even the naming of
it was messed up, right?
So we had AppCompat.
And then we had
specific utilities.
Recycler view was in there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There
is a lot of stuff.
CHET HAASE: All these
different things--
it was a sandbox of
stuff, all very useful.
What we're doing with Jetpack
is sort of putting it together
into cohesive parts.
So there are these modules that
you can use either together
or separately for shipping it
in a more robust and predictable
manner.
We made sense out of the APIs.
We refactored it with a
namespace that made sense.
We took a lot of the
capabilities that we had
and we put it into a
more sensible form that
solves one of the biggest
problems with Android
for developers,
which is how do I
develop for multiple
versions of Android
because that is the
developer reality.
Right?
So the ability to actually
write to a single API
and have it work on releases
all the way back to API 14
right now, I think, is huge.
And for us to be able to do that
in a way where they can make
sense out of those APIs and
the documentation and the maven
artifacts they have to get,
I think, is really huge.
What was the other question?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Something that
you still want to make better.
CHET HAASE: Everything, I want
to make everything better.
This is software.
We have bugs.
We have features
we want to work on.
We have APIs that we regret,
because that's how APIs work.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
CHET HAASE: So
honestly, everything
can get better all the time.
I feel good about where
we're at, especially given
where we were coming from.
But I also feel like we
have a lot further to go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
That's fair.
All right.
So your Twitter profile,
which I looked at recently--
CHET HAASE: It
must be the truth.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --on
research for this interview,
says you're the lead for
the Android UI toolkit.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
what's that like?
CHET HAASE: So the
first thing that
tells me is that I need to
go update my Twitter profile.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is my
subtle way of saying that.
CHET HAASE: It is out of date.
So I was the lead for the
Android UI toolkit team.
So when I joined in 2010, I
joined the UI toolkit team.
I worked on animations and
graphics and performance and UI
stuff.
And eventually, managed the team
for about the last five years,
as the team was
growing, doing things
like Jetpack and architecture
components and all
the normal platform
toolkit stuff.
And then about three
months ago, I made a change
and moved to a team called
Developer Relations.
I don't know if you
know what that is?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
I've heard of them.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Sure.
CHET HAASE: So I made
that switch, dropped
all my management
responsibilities on the floor,
and I'm now a developer
advocate in DevRel.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Well, that's great.
CHET HAASE: I think so.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Welcome to
the light side or dark side?
CHET HAASE: I consider
it the light side.
Because you know what, new
jobs always look better.
And then they become old jobs.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's
hope this one stays
the light side for some time.
CHET HAASE: No, I'm
excited about it.
So the way I look
at the job changes,
I now get to do my
hobby as my real job.
I was doing dev rel stuff.
I was doing a bunch of outreach.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Don't tell them.
CHET HAASE: Why?
[LAUGHTER]
My bosses won't watch it.
It doesn't matter.
But I've been doing dev rel
since I got here, right?
I really love doing the
outreach stuff with developers.
But I always felt
guilty about that
because that wasn't
actually my day job.
And now it is.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
You're welcome, world.
OK.
Something else that you
do that I want to mention
is the ADB podcast, the
Android Developers Backstage.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So for the
handful of people watching
that haven't subscribed
to that podcast yet--
CHET HAASE: Wait, what?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --it
could be a couple--
what episode is your favorite
that they should start with?
CHET HAASE: OK.
I'm going to start by saying
they are all my children.
And there is no
favorite among them.
But if I had to pick, I would
go way back in the archives
to back when our audio quality,
frankly, was very poor.
So you're going to have
to suffer through it.
It's going to sound
like one of those 1930s,
just past the talky
transition movies.
But we talked to on Anwar,
who was at that time
managing the art team.
We talked to him about how
garbage collectors work.
And it was so fascinating.
So my favorite thing
about doing ADB is we
get to learn how stuff works.
We are not talking to people
about stuff that we know.
We're talking about stuff
that we don't, by definition.
Oh, I'd like to learn
more about travel, or art,
or Android Studio, or
performance, or whatever.
We grab people on the team that
know more about that stuff.
And we have a
conversation with them.
So we had a
conversation with Anwar.
And we were so interested that
our little 45 minute episode
stretched onto an
hour and a half
before we ran out of words.
And we cut it into two episodes.
So probably my favorite,
because it best
represents the oh, my gosh, do
we get into the details part.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
The art episode-- sss.
CHET HAASE: Sss-- art episodes--
there's two.
It's like 30s,
somewhere in the 30s.
And we're now at 112.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Thanks for joining us, Chet.
CHET HAASE: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Next up, let's finish
things off with some machine
learning demos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAIGE BAILEY: I'm Paige
Bailey, a TensorFlow developer
advocate.
And I'm here today with
Carla Bromberg, who's
going to tell us all about
our AI for social good efforts
at Google.
So tell us a little bit
more about it, Carla.
CARLA BROMBERG: Thanks, Paige.
So for AI for
social good, we aim
to accelerate the application
of machine learning
to the world's
biggest humanitarian
and environmental issues.
So today I'm going to
tell you about some
of the core research
and engineering work
we're doing a lot
more specifically,
the flood forecasting
initiative.
PAIGE BAILEY: Excellent.
So is this the flood
forecasting initiative here?
CARLA BROMBERG: Yes.
So this is our demo.
And so what this shows you
is how we're using machine
learning to help
forecast and predict
with better accuracy
where floods are.
So that way we can
tell users when
they're affected by floods.
So earlier today
in the keynote, we
announced that we're
rolling this out
across a big portion of India.
And I'm going to
actually show you
the simulation that we have
for the demo here today.
So this simulation is over
the course of 48 hours.
So if you look, you can
see the water filling in.
So this is without
using machine learning.
You can see that the
accuracy is not very high.
And you can see
also that there's
a lot of regions that are
predicted to have floods.
Now with Google's flood
forecasting effort,
you can see, as you both use
the elevation maps that we've
been working on that involve
machine learning as well
as the models that we've made,
how much more accurate it is.
So if you're a person
who lives in this region,
earlier it would have
said it was flooding
and then you would
have to evacuate,
or you would think that
you need to evacuate.
But actually, when you look
at the more precise models,
you'll actually be safe.
So what we're hoping
is through this work
you can see that accuracy
has gone up to 79%.
And then when people
get the alerts,
they can have the
information that they need.
So as you can see
on the phone, what
they'll see moving into
this monsoon season
is when you search on Google,
or when you go into Google Maps
and you're in an
affected region,
it'll give you some more
information so that you know
how to keep yourself
and your family safe
and whether or not
you should evacuate
and when you get an alert
from Google public alerts.
PAIGE BAILEY: This is fantastic.
My academic background
is very focused
on quantitative hydrogeology
and geospatial reasoning.
And it's amazing to be able to
see the kind of accuracy uptick
that you get just by
using machine learning
with your elevation maps.
This is really, really cool.
CARLA BROMBERG: Thank you.
We're really excited.
And we hope we can save a lot
of lives ahead of this monsoon
season.
And we're hoping to also
expand this work across more
countries.
And for this, we're
partnering really
closely with the
Indian government,
and many others on the
ground, and first responders.
So hopefully, we can
help get the word out
so that people can
evacuate to safety.
PAIGE BAILEY: Thank you so much
for telling me about this work.
And let's go and take a
look at the other demo
that we have from
AI for social good
that's very focused
on whale detection
CARLA BROMBERG: Yeah.
Absolutely.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hi.
I'm here with Julie Cattiau.
And she's here to tell me about
this really cool whale demo.
JULIE CATTIAU: Yeah.
Nice to meet you.
So this is a demo that's related
to the bioacoustics project
at Google.
So we're a small team, part of
the AI for social good efforts.
And so we've been
training machine
learning model to detect
the presence of animals
just by listening
to the audio sound.
And so this project,
in particular,
is a partnership with
NOAA, the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric
Administration, which is part
of the American government.
NOAA in particular has a
network of microphones.
These microphones have
been set up in 2005.
And they're in different
spots in the Pacific Ocean.
And so in the end, it
adds up to a lot of data.
And so NOAA, the data said
that NOAA in particular
was interested in getting
our help to analyze.
It is close to 200,000
hours of audio.
So as you can imagine, nobody
can listen to the whole thing.
It's just way too long.
And that's where machine
learning can be very helpful.
Because with enough
examples of sounds,
machine learning can be
applied to recognizing
a particular species of animals
just by listening to the sound.
And actually, if you think about
animals that live in the ocean,
almost all of them produce
some sort of sound, even fish,
which can be surprising.
Boats definitely
make a lot of noise.
They're not animals,
but they make noise.
Whales make sounds.
Dolphins do, too.
And so the question
for us was can we
identify which species our
present in audio data set
and classify them using
artificial intelligence.
So this demo here
that you can see
represents three months
worth of data from that data
set I was telling you about.
And what you can
do is, if you slide
this table along the data, you
can see that this is actually
a spectrogram.
So it's a visual
representation of a sound.
This is frequency over time
for a particular sound.
And so NOAA provided some
examples of humpback whale
sounds.
And then we trained the
model to recognize the sounds
automatically.
And we used this on
the whole pile of data
that they had to tell
them where the whales were
and at which point in time.
When the color is light blue,
it means that our classifier
has detected a whale.
Would you like to listen
to the whale song?
EMILY FORTUNA: Absolutely.
JULIE CATTIAU: OK.
EMILY FORTUNA: So getting lots
of ocean sounds right now.
Oh, I hear the whale.
JULIE CATTIAU: You do?
EMILY FORTUNA: Awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
That's wonderful!
Well, thank you so much.
This is lovely.
JULIE CATTIAU: Thank you.
EMILY FORTUNA: It's
great that you're
able to track whale
migration patterns.
JULIE CATTIAU: Yeah.
Thank you for your interest.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There are a
few more sessions to come.
And later tonight,
we're all going
to rock out to the Flaming
Lips as they integrate machine
learning with their show.
That'll be at 8:30
tonight Pacific time.
So set your alarms
for what's going
to be an amazing performance.
And come back here tomorrow for
more special guests and demos.
We'll see you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]